welcome to this video ha what far 1
night 18 to wait okay yes black in the
room and let's see probably we get one
of my good old she go rinse yep again at
least I'm quick down having played this
for for ages a4 that's early okay let's
be quick here it's probably leading to
the same thing anyway with d 598 no it's
not why does rather miss placing some
pieces okay hmm interesting
gamming okay the night is really wrong
and b3 of it it's probably nothing that
I can exploit directly it's it's it's
it's always a misplaced but nothing
nothing to do nothing to do to really a
refute it let's just play a normal move
and see why is going
yeah just completing development yeah I
can take their night before but it's
nothing nothing special really okay
let's play that it's sort of justifies
his setup but it's still nothing nothing
special strange i spend any time on 92
yeah the weird sometimes okay so i'm
preparing rookie on d5 I want to have 98
need some square for this night
er not so easy just to see what what can
do now besides something like d 50 K is
blocking the whole thing yeah now i
don't i don't like to take that that's
mostly weakening my b5 pond but there's
really no no problem here it's a very
conventional position out of the closed
away where I'm a bit passive but really
not in any don't have any problem him
okay
don't don't really see anything terrible
happening here just need to check be
precise yeah so nice to da door to be
eight here might even have a choice I
can also give this check but it's not
helping you much I guess maybe I should
start like that nevertheless there's
also Queen a three ok I'm going to da it
is probably the the right square ok so
i'm going to enter here and put some
pressure here on the pawn and let's see
yeah this is a well known position type
where it is some normally yeah even a
little bit more uncomfortable for black
in this case I have this counter play
against c3 which always need some some
attention and I really should be should
be ok here one key idea is night
something like this night f7 and then
possibly be sure d 8 and later to be six
to get the what ok it's really really
strange ok
and some somewhat weird
hmm
should g4 maybe not clear
it's it looks a little bit weird to push
it here this early but maybe maybe it's
an interesting way for him to play is
Bishop g4 is this idea Oh interesting
now maybe Bishop g4 wasn't a great idea
what I did that possible I mean I don't
think I really have any problems but I
shouldn't have done this probably
when I see not just taking interesting
now if he takes I will get to recapture
with I mean both recaptures make sense
and taking on f6 is weird anyway I want
to go night g7 and possibly f5 I was
surprised that you push this so quickly
because very often it leaves weaknesses
behind that's a very direct move of
course ok let's take it very difficult
regrouping to g7 now if the night lens
on g4 it will be i mean this is this is
not easy I am no chief voice is coming
not sure how providing is it really is
but very very tough to play
maybe in check Wow don't really think
that this is so great but very difficult
to play
hard to part to evaluate
I just got Quincy five maybe maybe still
can play Quincy five check check check
check wait for things for my time yeah I
think it helped that i have played this
positional clock like a gazillion number
of times so i actually could play
quickly that's really always very
difficult a really difficult situation
maybe Bishop g4 wasn't really on I
really think that this is a little bit
of a premature expansion in general it's
okay there are two to do something but
I'm not sure if this was correctly timed
this is what I'm so I'm saying i think i
should actually not play Bishop g4 I
underestimated this idea with Bishop do
you wanna I should go back here
immediately and then here associate
getting in ideas like Bishop esri check
on putting some pressure here the thing
is that this is a somewhat strange
situation it looks good for white
because of the space and everything but
it's not so easy now to make any headway
and it can happen that my pieces that
look really passive that they get active
once let's say if white takes for
example all my pieces character so this
is not a totally clear situation in the
game I am he got got in this idea which
was really interesting but I still
should be okay I believe
takes AI know this regrouping queen age
3 was interesting well okay but the
census shouldn't be so bad jack Bishop
Bishop takes a stronger and this okay
intending g5 and Knight f6 okay yeah I
didn't have much time I was thinking
that this is also interesting because it
gets some it gets the night to d6 but it
is probably not that great he can play
the Queen invasion to be six or to see
five but he went here now he's in
trouble because I get the age 6 pawn
check check yeah yeah here why this lost
now he had some chances here certainly
but it was difficult of course now he
had very little time ok thanks for
watching